hello everyone and welcome back to round
three well game three of the match uh
dingler and versus magnus carlsen in the
magnus invitational
and if you thought that the the madness
would end after
after two games uh well you couldn't uh
you couldn't be more wrong because here
uh ding again goes for e4 and magnus now
replies with c5 and
you think okay he's now gonna go for
some uh normal stuff uh you know as
he did prepare this for for his world
chess championship match against the
caruana
so knight f3 knight c6 and bishop to b5
then goes for the rosso limo
and here if there was a normal game or
uh you might go for g6 which is the most
often played move here if you were
having a really good day you might even
go for g5
which is uh you know played maybe if
you're if you're if you're really having
a good day and if
maybe it's not a really important game
maybe it's a blizz game or something
but here magnus goes for h5 and already
as of move three we have
a completely new game this move has
never been played in in top tier uh
top tier uh chess games uh and it's it's
very interesting how does this h5
uh work with the russell emo so uh ding
of course
probably never saw this movie in his
life and he has to react to it somehow
so first he goes h4
h3 probably always a useful move
taking away g4 from from black's pieces
in the future
and also prevents h3 h4 h3 in the future
so i'm just
just waiting to see what carlson's plan
is here carlson continues with e6 he
wants the strike in the center with d5
we have c3
uh being also with with the same idea
and now knight to f4 not allowing thing
to execute d4 as the e4 pawn is under
attack
so here instead of defending with d3
like magnus did
in the previous game he goes e5 and
challenges the knight with knight to d5
and now d4 by magnus
we have c captures on d4 uh sorry biting
c captures on d4 by magnus and the ding
just castles here
we have d captures in c3 knight captures
we have knight captures and b
uh the and b captures and here uh white
uh wipes down a pawn but
he has a lot of open lines that he can
use to attack
so queen to c7 magnus just continues
development and
rook to e1 now defending the e5 pawn
b6 preparing to fianchetto the bishop
would bishop to b7 and
now dingoes for knight to g5 uh he's
preparing a queen to f3
uh to go to go for this spawn and if
you're thinking about
grabbing a pawn like it's a free pawn or
something then bishop to f4
and it's uh it's it's a problem since
now there's a double attack on your
knight here and after a bishop
bishop here you're going to get queen
here and it's just going to be a
a lot of free moves for white so instead
after this knight to g5 we have bishop
to b7 by magnus
and now queen to f3 dean goes for that
f7 pawn and this is where the
where the uh well where the party really
starts
here magnus just captures an e5 he says
okay i'm attacking your queen defending
f7 and also there's now
an open attack from my bishop to your
queen so
dean goes uh queen to f4 says okay now
there's a double attack on your knight
and if you move it i'm just going to
capture on f7
and magnus just defense bishop to d6 so
what was ding's idea here
well here dink played rook captures on
e5 and he eliminated defend the defender
of the f7 square
and the magnus uh went for bishop
captures uh
on e5 although uh a a slightly more
accurate move
would have been castles uh but then it
it seems it's just like a force draw it
is a disgusting engine line of course
uh but uh i am going to show it as it's
very interesting so you castle the
safety first
prepare to capture next but now ding
would have queen to h for going for
captures and mate
so if you react to this then you no
longer get a chance to capture the rook
so f6 is what you have to play here you
have to go for the knight
queen captures threatens mate here so
captures on g5 and
now bishop to d3 again with the same
mating idea bishop d3 check follow
followed by bishop g6 and queen h7 mate
so
rook captures on f2 making some room for
your king here and
now uh to not lose white would have to
settle for a draw here
check king f8 check king f7 uh and now
queen to h5 check
with a repetition here so this is uh
basically what happens if carlson goes
for the for the castle's move which is
the more precise move
however magnus captured it right away
and now he allows ding the initiative
queen captures an f7 with check king to
d8 and
now bishop to a3 uh and here carlson has
to
has to block this bishop with bishop to
c6 or or start
running away with the king then make
room for for the king on b7 for example
to get this rook into the game
uh but magnus just went for asics
instead
it's a very very greedy move uh but it's
not just that it's greedy it also
completely blunders the game
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea for ding
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations there are two
winning options here
one is the one ding played and the other
one is is a bit more forcing so
congratulations if you found either of
those
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it's knight
captures an e6 with check but also rook
8 to d1 works as this is what being
played
so we're just going to show captures
first as it's it pretty much ends the
game
on the spot there's a fork here so you
have to capture the knight if you don't
want to part with your queen
and now the hard move to find the queen
captures on e6 you don't allow the king
to escape here and now you have these
bishops slicing all the way here the
queen
prevents the king from escaping and next
move rook to d1 ends the game there is
no way black
and black can meet this move uh but
dean went with a with a slightly
different move order he went to rook to
d1 first and now it kind of looks like
he gave
magnus a chance to save his king with
king to c8 which is
what magnus played but ding just
continues uh
very fiercely with rook captures on d7
here magnus finds a very interesting
idea bishop to h2 check
point is that you have to choose king h1
or king f1
if you go king to f1 then queen captures
on c3
and white can no longer win this game
you don't have a continuation you don't
have a useful check
and after something like bishop rook
captures on b7
uh you might even lose the game because
after queen to a1 check uh you're just
at mercy of the black queen queen e2
you're gonna capture here
with check king e1 or something you're
gonna go queen b1 check now you can even
capture this bishop
uh and so on so not not much you can do
here or if you go for example to e1
uh then you have queen to b1 check again
and if you move king d2 now you capture
on b5 while defending d7 so you don't
allow mate
and rook to d8 is coming if you play
something like knight captures here then
just queen d5
check uh picks up the rook here so a
really tricky position but
a lot of poison to the position which
magnus finds with this bishop to h2 move
however ding goes for king to h1 and now
magnus doesn't really have a good
continuation here you don't have a
square for your queen all of these are
covered by the bishops
uh uh well you could capture on c3 uh
but uh
that's uh now it's not now it's not very
useful uh now here uh
you just play bishop to f8 it's uh there
are other moves that win of course you
could play king captures here but bishop
to f8
is the most straightforward one uh with
the with the simple thread of queen here
with
which will deliver checkmate uh so you
would have to go for something like
queen to b8
instead but still it is very winning uh
here
there's a very nice trick rook to d8
check you sacrifice the rook and after
real captures queen captures on e6 with
check and now it's just a nice queen c4
check king has to move uh and after
well no king cannot move anywhere since
the bishops are slicing all the way here
you have to block and queen captures
uh and c6 is checkmate so here after
king to h1 by ding magnus decides
okay i have to give up the queen and now
dink just captures it with
check we have rook captures bishop
captures it back so you don't
lose the bishop as well and now knight
captures on e6 uh threatening checkmate
on c7
with bishop to e5 uh
centralizing the bishop and not allowing
checkmate and bishop to f8 now ding
finds the the move that we also uh
looked at in the other line again uh
these squares are covered the queen to
e8 will be checkmate
so bishop the c6 not allowing that but
now just bishop captures on g7 forcing
more traits
uh bishop to d6 you cannot you cannot
capture of course because it's just
instant mate so the bishop has to keep
an eye on this square
but now just bishop captures an h8 and
here rook
captures an a2 by magnus he still has
the two bishops in the rook there might
be some back rank issues here
but dean goes for queen g8 check king to
d7
and now just knight to f8 check which
wins the rook
uh so it was in this position on mu 27
that magnus calls and resign the game
so really wild stuff game three every
game every game incredible i have no
idea
what what they're doing well what magnus
is doing
i mean it's working everyone's having a
lot of fun here and everyone is enjoying
it so so i do encourage it
uh but yeah he resigned because after
you eliminate check just for queen
captures here and now it's queen and
bishop against two bishops so of course
completely winning for
uh for ding so yeah uh that's uh the
game i do hope you enjoyed it and
we can only hope that game four
continues in the same fashion uh with
some
with some crazy crazy moves uh but yeah
you know if you're
if you're uh if you face bishop to b5
dorotholimo do give
h5 a try if you enjoyed it uh so yeah
once again i do hope you enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank animal mohanty
uh met hot salem uh tono corvitz colin
packard and thomas valeri for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the fourth game probably of
the
ding carlson match and we can only hope
that it ends by carlson winning so we
have an even crazier armageddon
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day